from our good friends over at clown  world did we talk about this one yet guy  with mask got mad because some guy walks  too close to him without wearing a mask  yes this is uh This Is Where We Are  turn the volume down  [Music]  you're gonna go to jail look at these  people with the masks on right  so so hold on just like consider this  this guy is mad that some guy was close  and without a mask on so he wants to get  closer to him yeah it's always the  tightest mask too with these people and  they get so mad they have like maybe  it's the pressure you know the pressure  and it's causing their head to yeah  serious question though with stuff like  this  what happened to people's brains now  hold on did they never have one or did  something break it they were easily they  were fragile to begin with  I think a lot of these people